let's go to connie yeah my 21 year old
son
had a terrible car accident last fall
and basically it crushed his left arm
he is floundering he does not know
what he's going to do for a vocation
his hobbies his identity his
his everything is based on two
arms and we're still in the mix of
of surgeries i mean he just had surgery
this morning actually
another one so um
i don't know how to help him so what was
he doing
as a profession um just finished school
to be a mechanic
oh man and that's all he ever wanted to
do
and has he lost all function in this
hand and this arm
um essentially they're doing just a
what do they call it salvage where he
won't be able to move his elbow all the
way and he's still waiting for his
nerves
his wrist doesn't work properly yet
that's a whole nother
surgery set of surgeries coming up
they saved his arm but it doesn't look
the same
he lifted weights for three hours a day
before this
you know he's it's never going to be the
same it's never going to work the same
and he just i mean that was his
everything so i just
i worry about him and trying to figure
out how to help him
so let's start with you um you said the
word never
several times this has affected you too
in a really an existential way walking
me through how you've been feeling the
last few months
don't make me cry dr john hey you called
me dude
you called me yesterday walking me
through it how are you
i'm fine until i start talking about it
i miss my son yeah i miss his presence
he's a big guy and he's lost 35 pounds
he's he's not he may see anybody's thin
and he's tall and he was all muscle
before
and he doesn't walk straight anymore he
he you know he just he has to laugh a
lot more he doesn't he laughs once in a
while but he doesn't laugh as much as he
used to
he just um he just isn't the same person
so it makes me sad yeah are you the same
person
no absolutely not i'm not the same
person but it's not
yeah i am where'd you go
who are you now
i have to put my fixer hat back on i am
a fixer i've been through a lot of crap
with
over the years with my husband died
seven years ago which did not help the
sun
i've had breast cancer i've um
i'm a widow yeah like i said before um
i am a fixer i will get through this it
doesn't all
it doesn't ultimately affect my life
my job is to fix him up and send him
back this happened out of state
and he's back with me now and we get
along fine that's
not an issue but um
i'm trying to help him he doesn't even
know what he doesn't know yet
right or what he does know yet i mean
we're still
you know to a 21 year old this what
three and a half months is a drop in the
bucket for his wife
but to him it's his whole life right now
it's he just wants his life back
right
how how honest do you want me to be with
you
i can i can be real honest with you or i
and
i can or i can give you some some tips
be honest with me i i make him mad
sometimes because i'm an optimist and i
say things
that he's like mom you don't know that
you don't know if it's going to be
better and i said but you don't know
that it is going to be as horrible as
they say it's going to be like they
don't know because they don't see this
walk in the door every day this is a
very weird
um surgeons are brilliant but um
it's up to him for a lot of this too
about how much he gets back and doesn't
get back
and luck you know it's just
all of that but so he can do whatever he
wants to do
i think you are a
you desperately desperately want to be
an optimist
and i think you say the right things and
you
can you can become that as a as you can
reach into your tools bag of fix it for
everyone around me
and one of the tools is light in the
room and you know how to
turn that tool on but i think this has
rocked you from the inside out
and i think you are as scared and
nervous
and heartbroken about his future
probably more so than he is
you are right he's 21 he's a teenager
basically
right um
and here's the thing
you can't fix him right right i can't
fix him
you can't and there's no worse feeling
for a parent in the whole world
and to watch someone that you love hurt
and you've done this before
and you couldn't fix that one either
right
right and some people respond to that
that level of powerlessness by
letting go of everything and others say
that will never happen again and they
clamp down even tighter and tighter
and then a second thing like this can
rattle somebody to their core
right was were you involved in this
wreck in any way
no did you raise a good young man
as a single mom yes oh yes does he love
his wife
he's single oh he's single okay i
thought he said he had a wife okay
no um is he somebody that you're proud
of
yes like not just like um pretend but
are you proud of the man he's turning
into yes
i am okay then i want you to know that
you did
your best and that you did good
the most gracious thing you could give
him right now
is a couple of honest truthful responses
you can let them know hey i'm
heartbroken for you as your mom
and i'm not going to tell you
everything's going to be okay it's going
to be
but it's going to be different some of
the words you used when you first called
was
he's never going to be the same he's
never going to get it back he doesn't
look the same
and that this is all going to be this
way
and man he just wants to get his life
back he wants to get this back we just
want to get i want him to get his body
back
and here's the thing it's not going to
come back it's going to be different
right and it can be a different kind of
good
and it can be a different kind of
awesome and a different kind of could
never have imagined it
but it's not going to be that right and
so
the more he feels a disconnect between
the words coming out of your mouth and
the mom he knows and can
feel the more he's going to have to put
on his fix-it face
so that he doesn't hurt you and you're
going to get into this weird dance of
making sure the other person's always
okay
and nobody's ever telling each other the
truth that hey this
really sucks and this is scary and this
is not the rest of your life but it kind
of is the rest of your life you know all
that that pattern right
and ugh i so
this for you as it comes to him
you nailed it man you know exactly he's
lost multiple
identities right the identity of that
sucks for men is that you're only worth
what you can achieve and you can only
work like you're only worth what you
accomplish through
your big muscles and he's a weightlifter
and he's a mechanic
and he's an able-bodied person and and
and right so
that part for the time being is is
squashed
beneath those things are
the more important virtuous traits
somebody who gets back up somebody who
gets back in the ring
somebody who does the grinding grueling
every day of rehab even without knowing
if this is going to work or not
someone who endures yet another surgery
somebody who is still kind and
respectful
and begins to say okay cool life dealt
me two twos
and a three not a great hand so i'm
gonna have to figure another way to play
and that's gonna come if you really lean
in to encourage him to grief
a massive grief process don't compare
and put him on a timeline don't force
him to be joyful and optimistic but put
boundaries on him
that say yeah you're allowed to be sad
and your butt's at my house so
i'm gonna expect you to get up and take
the trash out you can carry that with
one arm
that's a giant arm right and you're
um your butt's gonna make breakfast too
right okay um
i don't know if this is a appropriate
place for this it is what it is we're
already into it so my best friend on
planet earth
was um my oldest friend
that i've ever met that i've ever known
since we were zero
um after college was in a life-altering
car wreck
and i'll never forget um he has very
little use of
all his arms and legs anymore he's still
still close we still keep in contact on
a regular basis
and he's one of the most heroic
extraordinary people i've ever met
and his little brother and another
neighborhood friend of ours are still
friends to this day
and i'll never forget the conversation
that the three of us had around pancakes
while he was still in the hospital
and we said what are what do we do now
and we decided we're going to continue
to treat them
like somebody that we love which means
we're going to still pick on him we're
still going to give him a hard time
we're still going to have high
expectations for him
we're still going to love him and if
he's got to go to the bathroom we're
going to help out
and we're going to invite him to the
concerts and we're going to
help him with his wheelchair too does
that make sense it became
everything it became all of it all at
the same time
and it just became a new different life
and i know he wouldn't trade anything to
go back to be able to run
and be free and play pick up basketball
i don't make any
like illusions about that but i do know
that
all of his heart his family's hearts all
of our hearts have
grown because we said we're still going
to have high expectations for you we're
still going to treat people with dignity
with kindness with love we are going to
continue to default to you we're going
to continue to support you right
so when i tell you that you've been
through you've been through heavy heavy
loss before
tell me how that how is it going to be
different this time
well before it was not say
just mental but it was just mental
we went through some stuff let me tell
you he's my youngest
and we went through a lot of stuff and
i think some of that's still there for
him
that's part i think that's part of the
issue too
um
this is physical though this this is
mental and physical
it's spiritual it's who am i right it's
who i am
yes yes who am i if i'm not muscles and
i'm not a mechanic and i'm not the big
strong guy my mom needs who am i
and for you if yet another person i love
got hurt
god oh my who am i right
and you are a resilient strong
smart loving mom who is
i think ready to go one step below where
you've been
which is pretending which is trying to
prop him up which is saying hey
it's all gonna be okay you're gonna keep
working hard and you're gonna keep
maybe not maybe not
maybe you're not going to be a mechanic
anymore you're still going to be person
to character you're still going to be my
boy you're still going to be worth being
loved
and we're going to figure out what's
next right i'm still going to have
boundaries you're not going to be ugly
in my house
right you're not gonna be ugly at my
house
but we're gonna laugh i'm gonna give you
a hard time
and my oldest friend on planet earth
he still can't run he's still
wheelchair-bound he will be for the rest
of his life
but i still love him he still
accomplished a lot and encouraged
a lot a lot of people he still brings me
joy it makes me laugh and makes me
frustrated makes me angry when he sends
me stupid political stuff
he still makes me cry
and i named my kid after him
i named my son after him and so his
legacy will continue on and continue on
and continue on and i tell you that to
tell you this
what your son needs is all of you
not pretend you not almost you
not the one that wants to fix but knows
deep down you can't
he wants you he needs you and now on the
hard days he's gonna really need you
on the easy days he's gonna need you
he's gonna need to learn boundaries he's
gonna need to
dig deep and find himself he's probably
gonna need a professional counselor you
know that
you might benefit from one as well
but this won't define him if people
around him tell him the truth if people
give him space to grieve whatever that
looks like and doesn't compress and put
weird time limits on it like you should
be picking it up by now but also holds
him accountable
he says you do got to go to work you're
going to learn a new skill
and he is blessed to have you as a mom
he's blessed blessed to have you as a
mom connie
i want you to keep us surprised of how
he's getting better
i want you to let us know how things are
going and as he continues to
grow i'd love to have him call the show
i'd love to
to have a chat with him he sounds like
an awesome guy